Traductor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
El 4 de julio de 2015
la nave espacial de NASA "New Horizons"
estaba a 5 billones de km de la Tierra.
Estaba a solo 10 días de Plutón,
después de volar 9.5 años,
cuando de repente se quedó sin contacto.
Pero retrocedamos un poco.
A partir de 1989,
la Humanidad había enviado con éxito
naves a cada planeta del sistema solar
excepto uno: Plutón.
Habrás oído que los astrónomos
no consideran a Plutón
o a sus hermanos planetas.
Sin embargo, la mayoría
de científicos planetarios lo hacen,
por lo cual usamos esa terminología aquí.
Es limitado lo que podemos
aprender de Plutón desde la Tierra
porque está muy alejado de nosotros.
Plutón, sin embargo, es
una mina de oro científica.
está localizado en una región
llamada el Cinturón de Kuiper,
hogar de muchos planetas pequeños,
cientos de miles de ancianos
objetos helados,
y trillones de cometas.
Esta misteriosa región contiene pistas
de la formación de nuestro sistema solar,
y estaba tentadoramente
lejos de nuestro alcance.
Hasta "New Horizons".
Su objetivo: explorar Plutón,
recoger todos los datos
científicos que sea posible,
trasmitirlos de vuelta a la Tierra,
luego explorar más lejos
en el Cinturón de Kuiper.
Para conseguirlo, el equipo de
"New Horizons" equipó su nave
con instrumentos científicos
de tecnología punta.
Estos incluyen a Ralph,
un conjunto de cámaras tan potente
capturar las características del
tamaño de los edificio de Manhattan
desde decenas
hasta miles de km de distancia.
Y REX, diseñado para usar
ondas de radio
para medir la presión atmosférica
de Plutón y su temperatura.
Todo el equipo a bordo tenía que
ser a la vez confiable y ligero
porque el "New Horizons"
tenía un reto adicional;
tenía que alcanzar su objetivo
lo antes posible.
¿Por qué?
Alrededor de 2020, Plutón alcanzará
un punto en su órbita
donde la atmósfera podría congelarse.
Y debido a la inclinación de su eje,
cada vez más superficie de Plutón
está envuelta en oscuridad cada año.
Plutón completa una órbita completa
una vez cada 248 años,
sería una larga espera hasta
la siguiente oportunidad de visitarlo.
Para ver como "New Horizons"
llegó a Plutón a tiempo,
avancemos hasta su lanzamiento.
Sus tres cohetes estadificadores
aceleraron a una velocidad tan grande
que cruzó los 400 000 km
hacia la Luna en sólo nueve horas.
Cerca de un año después,
la nave alcanzó Júpiter
y obtuvo lo que llamamos
un asistente gravitatorio.
Ahí es donde vuela lo suficiente cerca
del gigante gaseoso
para recibir un efecto
gravitacional de tirachinas.
Entonces "New Horizons" estaba
volando a cerca de 50 000 km por hora,
como lo haría los siguientes ocho años
para cruzar el golfo restante de Plutón.
Ir a una velocidad tan asombrosa
significa que la desaleración
para entrar en órbita o aterrizar
habría sido imposible.
Por eso que "New Horizons"
estaba en misión de sobrevuelo,
tenía una sola oportunidad de
pasar sobre Plutón y hacer observaciones.
El sobrevuelo sería
totalmente automático,
ya que a esa distancia,
los interntos de guiarlo a la TIerra
tardarían 4.5 horas en llegar.
El equipo puso un ordenador de
abordo con cientos de órdenes,
llamado código madre,
que comenzaría a trabajar cuando
la nave estuviera a 6.5 día de Plutón
Pero cuando a "New Horizons"
le quedaban 10 días para llegar,
casi ocurrió una tragedia.
El control de tierra perdió
contacto con la nave.
Después de dos angustiosas horas,
"New Horizons" volvió online,
pero el Control descubrió que
el ordenador principal se había reiniciado
perdiendo el código madre
y otra información crítica.
Sin eso, pasaría zumbando
junto a Plutón,
sin nada que mostrar a la misión.
Alice Bowman, la jefa de
operaciones de la misión,
lideró un equipo por 72 horas en vela
para conseguir que las instrucciones
fueran cargadas de nuevo
en el "New Horizons" a tiempo.
Sin espacio para errores,
ella y su equipo lo lograron,
y "New Horizons" empezó a tomar
y retransmitir imágenes impresionantes.
Estas obervaciones han revelado
un mundo deliciosamente variado
con nieblas terrestres,
calima a alta altitud,
posibles nubes,
cañones,
montañas imponentes,
fallas,
cráteres,
casquetes polares,
glaciares,
aparentes campos de dunas,
sospechosos volcanes de hielo,
evidencia de fluidos pasados,
y mucho más.
Un descubrimientos emocionante
es el Glaciar Sputnik Planitia
de 1000 km de ancho.
Sputnik Planitia está compuesto
por nitrógeno congelado batido,
y nunca hemos visto nada como
esto en nuestro sistema solar.
La exploración de Plutón
fue un gran éxito,
pero "New Horizons" aún no ha acabado.
En enero de 2019,
romperá su propio record por
el objeto más lejano explorado
cuando visite un objeto del Cinturón
de Kuiper llamado 2014 MU69,
que orbita alrededor del Sol otros
billones de km más lejos que Plutón.
El mundo contiene el aliento
para ver qué encontraremos allí.